my name is Nick Garris I was convicted
of the murder of a woman I never met at
the age of 20. I then spent the next 23
years in solitary confinement except for
a brief lapse when I escaped from Death
Row in 1985 spent 25 days on the FBI's
10 most wanted list until I had the
courage to turn myself back in I was
then returned to Pennsylvania where I
was originally sentenced to die I became
the first man in the United States to
seek DNA testing to prove my innocence
it took me 15 years and a letter to the
courts asking to die to get that
accomplished in 2004 I was released in
the 19 years that it preceded that I've
gone around the world teaching people
about neuroplasticity healing
the true Geordie podcast